[Music]
May was jam-packed with news about all
the big games you're looking forward to
so we come through the headlines to
bring you the biggest stories that
matter hit that subscribe button and
you'll get every news video delivered
right to you because we're about to
flood you with all that juicy ìiî
goodness now let's see what happened
this month
it's not just full games that got all
the attention in May we got our first
look at some breadth of the Wild DLC as
well the master trials expansion adds a
new hard mode which makes enemies
tougher and spreads them out to even
more locations on the map and speaking
of the map the new heroes paths feature
will chart up to 200 hours of play time
showing exactly where you've traveled
and if you need to backtrack you can use
the new travel medallion to create your
own fast travel point the expansion also
adds new equipment and masks including
the core rock mask which will make it
easier to track down those cute little
tree guys on top of all this you can
check out the new trial of the sword
challenge 45 rooms tons of enemies and
you start out with zero equipment good
luck and for an even closer look at all
this good stuff you can check out our
DLC theories video I know I'm hoping for
termina after that Majora's Mask reveal
[Music]
remember parappa the rapper um jammer
Lambie guitar room an Elite Beat Agents
chances are you've played at least one
of those and the two creators behind
those games have taken to Kickstarter to
launch a new rhythm adventure game it's
currently called Project wrap rabbit and
it looks like much more than just
pressing buttons in time with the music
it's all about rap battles so you'll
have to pick the best comebacks while
keeping up with the beat we can't tell
you how to spend your money but the game
is currently planned for ps4 and PC with
Nintendo switch and Xbox one versions as
stretch goals
[Music]
speaking of games you probably didn't
see coming back Darksiders 3 is totally
happening
we've played as war and death and now
it's time for fury to take the stage
she's the wildest horseman so far
battling with her whip and magic spells
her mission take down the seven deadly
sins and if I had to guess I'd say the
game Zelda influences mean we might see
temples themed after those sins so if
you need me I'll be hanging out with MV
because I really want to play this like
right now but we'll all have to wait
until 2018 okay so the name isn't
confirmed yet but Ubisoft has announced
that the next Assassin's Creed game will
launch this fiscal year so the latest
you'll be playing it is March 31st 2018
the studio also teased a logo on Twitter
with the phrase a new era begins so it
seems pretty clear that we'll be going
back to an earlier historical period
maybe Egypt like the rumors are saying
expect more at e3 in just a few weeks
and we'll have all the latest right here
but if you want to know more about
another Ubisoft game right now we've
also learned a lot about far cry 5 it's
said in Hope County Montana
it's full of gun-toting cultists and
there are plenty of forests and
mountains and rivers to explore you'll
be going up against Eden's gate and it's
charismatic leader father Joseph while
his family members keep the rest of the
cult in line just like with pretty much
everything else on this list expect to
see a lot more at e3 and those are the
hottest stories for the most anticipated
games this month so what else are you
looking forward to playing sound off in
the comments and remember you can always
grab our GameSpot app for all the most
popular stories available now on iOS and
this thursday on Android
see you at e3
you